[Applause]  down chips looking for that dagger  [Applause]  [Music]  part of that flight Budenholzer tree  [Music]  dodging step back  [Applause]  to give bazemore going give them an easy  dunk four point game  [Applause]  now cross the 14,000 point mark joining  Kevin Durant LeBron James and so  targeting a February return Zach Collins  also expected to return at some point  [Applause]  eleven points for Damian Lillard Don  Cheech wanted a whistle  [Applause]  three agents of a pain to shoot Don tics  will pull off  exchanging fire so want with Luca jaunt  Dantas I mean you got to like your  chances enemy  Dallas is started this game oh six from  the floor has